Originality isn't something static and it's just there for you at all times.
It's like inspiration, you gotta find it.
I don't think the key is to look for inspiration.
I think the key is to understand that everything is inspiring.
You know, the design kind of breeds the originality,...
...starting with a tool that's unique lends itself to making unique things.
Inspiration is a pretty strange beast.
Is it inspiration or is it an extraction?
Am I original or am I the sum of a lot of ideas that I accumulated over time?
Why am I inspired by something?
Why am I curious about something?
Why do I feel this connection?
Inspiration is just, it's that spark, and then all the rest is originality.
Inspiration can come from anywhere.
Originality is where you take it.